President Trump recently created an
office for his daughter Ivanka in the
White House and people say the office
gives Ivanka an unprecedented amount of
I'm sorry do you guys hear that
seriously what is that tapping noise
what is that it's Coney the cameraman he
was tapping his ring oh oh sorry Conan
I'm a little fidgety is it Easter yet
no Tony Easter isn't until Sunday what
he asked did you give up alcohol for
Lent and now you're really craving a
cold beer yeah how did you know who I
like you can't have a cold beer cuz you
made a $500 bet with your co-worker
Wayne they could stay on the wagon till
Easter and you can't you can't cheat cuz
one of the conditions of the bet was to
take a breathalyzer every day in front
of Wayne's brother ray who's a cop
Conan how the hell did you know you
thought maybe you could get around the
breathalyzer test by drinking beer in
the morning because the alcohol would be
out of your system by the time you left
work so you tried that this morning you
went to the fridge and garage but your
wife Eileen caught you red-handed and
said I'm gonna rat you out to wait
unless you give me five hundred bucks
isn't that right Tony isn't that right
holy crap it's like you read my mind I
didn't read your mind I've read the cue
cards cue cards when you want to know
what's coming up next
kill cars that's right guys so Jesus
what did you think of our sketch oh
thanks thanks for asking I liked how it
started with Tony over there talking
about Lent and Easter but then it got a
little weird when you knew all about
Tony's life because everything's on cue
cards I got to be honest you lost Jesus
on that one still I liked it I'm gonna
give that sketch three out of five halos
[Music]
thanks Jesus no problem just uh one
other thing Conan can can i plug my
resurrection yeah okay but we're a
little tight make it quick with giggles
hey everybody this Sunday April 16th I'm
coming back from the dead so go to
church check it out Sunday morning or
midnight Easter Vigil that counts but
get there early parking is going to be a
[ __ ]
[Music]
that's true
Wow what an important part of our show
you